now for more on the spike in cases and
the latest studies on the importance of
wearing masks we are joined by cbs news
medical contributor
dr david agus david let's start with the
spike in cases
in reopening people expected to see the
numbers go up so how much of this is
what we expected and how much of this
should we be very concerned about
you know the number of cases is under
our control
as we open the doors and let people out
you know you can either
wear a mask and social distance and
practical behavior
that we know stop spread of the virus or
you can go back to
the way the normal was before the virus
and
many people have gone back to the way
the normal was they come home
and they could spread the virus and
obviously that gets worrisome when we're
tracking it about a
thousand deaths a day presently in the
united states
you mentioned the masks and there's a
recent study out of england
there's a quote a key message that
people can take away
my mask protects you your mask protects
me
you've seen this study what can you tell
us of the importance in it
you know it's real i mean the data are
that if you wear a cloth mask you block
droplets coming out of your face
and it blocks those droplets from
spreading virus to others
period and so we need to normalize that
behavior in japan where they wore masks
when they were sick to stop
spread to others before this virus
they're now
all wearing mass and they have very
little spread of the virus this behavior
here though isn't normal and people are
saying
it's my right not to wear a mac we all
have to stand up for each other as a
community and if we wear mass we will
stop spread of the virus this study in
england
definitively show that it will decrease
significantly transmission of the virus
it's sort of pick or choose if you'd
like to have things opening up this is
one way at least that you can try
to prevent some of the spread
asymptomatic spread has obviously been a
concern throughout
and then we heard from the world health
organization
some troubling uh news i guess earlier
this week
one report was that it was very rare
that there was asymptomatic spread
they walked that back can you give us
the basics where we stand when it comes
to asymptomatic spread
yeah how dare the world health
organization you know spread information
that just isn't correct
they were talking about a very small
study in china that showed that there
was not
significant asymptomatic spread in that
particular community but across the
globe
there have been many studies now showing
that when you're asymptomatic there are
several days you can spread the virus to
others
and what we call pre-symptomatic spread
that is days before
you're symptomatic from the virus you
are contagious and can spread the virus
to others
so this is unfortunately one of the
dastardly ways this virus
can get out there is you think you're
well and you go out and you could spread
the virus to grandma
or grandpa and cause significant
problems
asymptomatic spread is real that is the
message asymptomatic spread is real
a lot of people hoping for a vaccine and
there's been so much
talk about where we stand in these
various trials
they're narrowing the field down a
little bit it looks like right now what
can you tell us
well dana this is the positive news is
that there are
a 130 efforts of vaccines across the
globe
they're choosing five and in those five
they're starting production now
so that the vaccine is ready in large
amounts if the drug works
and so the hope is is that these
vaccines
now which are entering the late stages
of phase 2 study
they went in they showed safety now
they're showing immune responses
and then we're going to do definitive
studies vaccine versus no vaccine and
show its stop spread of the virus
if they work they will be here in the
fall and so
operation warp speed has started
production on these five vaccines to get
them ready
in case that would be welcome news i
know for so many people out there dr
david agus
thank you